Mexican authorities
just arrested
five more people linked to the killing
and kidnaping of American tourists
and the cartel
and investigators believe is responsible
for the crimes.
Is now apologizing
to the victim's families.
The Gulf cartel also handed over
five of its members to local authorities.
Now the bodies of trade.
Woodard and Jane Doe Brown,
the two Americans killed in
that kidnaping
have been delivered to U.S.
diplomatic authorities.
The group of friends from South Carolina
drove to Matamoros,
Mexico, last Friday,
so one of them could get
a medical procedure.
Investigators believe they were mistaken
for drug smugglers.
CNN security correspondent
Josh Campbell joins us now.
And Josh, this apology letter,
it seems highly unusual.
What more are you learning about
how it came about?
Yeah, be honest.
Days after
the kidnaping
of these four American citizens,
in Mexico,
the cartel that is suspected to be behind
this appears to be doing
some PR image cleanup,
of course, cartel known for its violence,
known for its brutality.
But yesterday, this letter surfaced.
The so-called apology letter now
obtained a copy from a sources
familiar with this investigation.
I'll read you part of it.
It says that
the Gulf cartel apologizes
to the society of Matamoros.
The relatives of Miss O'Reilly,
that was a Mexican national
who was killed in this attack.
And the affected
American people and families,
it goes on to say, the Gulf
Cartel Scorpion Group
strongly condemns
the events of last Friday.
For this reason,
we decided to hand over
those directly involved
and responsible for the acts.
Now it's worth pointing out
that the source that I spoke
with said that U.S.
and Mexican law enforcement,
they doubt the sincerity of this apology.
Again,
it appears to be said
in response
to all the attention
that has come upon this group,
of course, we have U.S.
officials who have been demanding
that the US government
do more to help
try to curb some of the violence
at the US-Mexico border.
So again,
the sincerity of that letter
is certainly in question.
But they mentioned as part of that letter
that they handed over
members of their group.
There was a photo that surfaced online
showing five men on the pavement,
their shirts pulled over their heads.
We could not confirm that
that was an actual
those were actually part
of this incident.
But the Mexican officials
today announced that they have arrested
five people.
That was a mug shot that you just saw.
Again, still unclear
what their exact alleged role was here.
But, of course,
the families of those who were kidnaped
particularly those who were killed
in that attack, are demanding justice.
In fact,
our colleague Carlos Suarez
spoke to
the mother
of one of the surviving members,
and she wants to see law enforcement
go forcefully after this
group, telling
Carlos that they need
to keep getting them
until they get them all guys.
Now, I mentioned
that the bodies of Shade Woodard
and Jane Doe Brown,
those are now with us
diplomatic authorities where officials.
What happens next?
Yeah.
So those remains were repatriated
back to the United States.
A source familiar
with this process tells me that
there will now be a second
autopsy that's conducted.
There was an autopsy conducted
by Mexican officials.
Of course,
this crime
occurred in their jurisdiction.
But this is interesting
and I think signals for us
where the FBI investigation is
going, U.S.
authorities are going
to conduct their own autopsies.
I can tell you, having worked
these murder cases in the past overseas,
that when the FBI is building
a case
for possible prosecution,
they would like, you know,
for basically for simplicity and ease
to have an American doctor
conduct an autopsy
so they have their own results.
And then that person could be easily
called to testify
if there is an eventual prosecution
and extradition.
So a lot going on behind the scenes
as authorities both on the U.S.
and Mexican side try to investigate
those who are responsible
for this brutal, brutal attack us.